well new york state sparking confusion
as they reverse the decision to lift the
indoor mask mandates
across all schools and camps statewide
at the last minute arguing that they
need more information from the cdc
we're going to modify the cdc guidance
and allow schools to choose
no mask outside for children
in other words children wear masks
in school inside there is no mandate
for masks outside but with infection
rates low among children why are our
officials so afraid of following the
science
here now to discuss this u.s
congressional candidate for new york liz
joy
fox news medical contributor dr mark
siegel and nurse and mother of three in
the albany area
carissa mayer good morning happy to see
all of you
well morning good morning so dr siegel
i'll start with you
because you are a medical expert
obviously you say that these mixed
messages
spread fear oh
incredibly of the politics of fear that
governor sounds like a principal you
would
never ever want to see he's coming after
you with a ruler right
i mean whatever happened to following
the science here he says he's waiting
for a 70
number a magic number where 70 percent
of adults are vaccinated one dose before
he
gets rid of all these restrictions we're
at 68 percent where did 70
come from ainsley also children that are
vaccinated have to wear masks in school
also new york state only had 500 new
cases yesterday and the positivity rate
is less than 0.5 percent the lowest in
the entire pandemic
also children are not spreaders they
rarely spread it
also any teacher can get vaccinated now
in any staff member
so of course schools are safe places of
course children should not have to wear
masks
if they feel like it if they're part of
a group that wants to wear masks inside
i'm all for it
it is not the science that they need to
do so right now
now chris i know you're a nurse you have
three children
how is this affecting you it's really
affecting me ainsley i have an
eight-year-old and ten-year-old
nathan and caleb attend voysville
elementary school and they've had to
wear masks both indoors and outdoors for
the entire school year
as a nurse and parent i'm very concerned
because nathan has immune deficiencies
um seizures and you know when his
temperature fluctuates
especially in this heat it's a very big
concern um and also some sensory
challenges
my son caleb comes home every day my
ears hurt um
he has asthma and most importantly as a
parent i'm worried about social images
and um you know body image issues with
this and the anxiety associated with it
as kids turn into the teenagers
and as dr siegel indicated there's no
clinical evidence
that you know wearing a mask makes sense
and also
that what the clinical evidence does say
is children at a much lower rate of
transmission and spreading the illness
at school
um if tolls is a hardship for my kids
and i'm really disappointed with
governor cuomo's decision right now
it's troubling that the state would make
a decision without sound evidence
and there's numerous negative and
medical implications
to wearing masks i mentioned earlier
the implications of my children but then
also claustrophobia fear
respiratory issues all kinds of things
that we have to look about look at and
also with learning
um kids are at a much lower rate of
learning academically
when their face is covered all day so
you know the decision to wear a mask to
me should be based on a parent's
decision
and not the state bureaucrats telling us
to do that
parents are frustrated i've talked to
our superintendent yesterday
and he tells me he's been getting floods
of emails and calls
but unfortunately the school system
can't make that clinical decision it has
to come from cdc and department of
health i want to get liz in here because
we haven't heard from liz
liz uh it's not just new york state
there are other states around the
country that are feeling this as well
what is your biggest concern well my
biggest concern here is the government
overreach
the our children do not belong to the
government
our children belong to us and we will
not comply with these mass mandates
what's happening here
is the fact that the government is
actually asking us to abuse our children
right if the department of social
services went to a home
in the summer with the heat and they saw
a child or a teenager
with their mask with their nose and
mouth covered all day long in
the heat and then put them in a vehicle
school bus
right um having to ride with their noses
and mouths covered that would be deemed
child
abuse and they would be removed well in
effect this is what the government is
actually asking
parents to do we will not comply we will
not do it
our children belong to us not the
government and i encourage every single
parent out there to go to the board of
education demand an emergency meeting
demand that a no mass policy be
immediately immediately
implement it if enough parents stand up
which i believe they
are we will win this battle we're not
going to comply it's really that simple
now dr siegel cuomo says that the cdc is
not going to update its mass guidance
for several weeks
what can parents do and why is it taking
the cdc so long
parents can do exactly what's being done
here we they can speak
out and say that this is absolutely
ridiculous and the points that were just
made
is that there's a huge physical downside
to masking and superimposing masking
especially with medical conditions what
a hypocrite the governor is
who said throughout the pandemic ainsley
that the state should make the decisions
now he's waiting for the cdc
now he waits for the cdc which of course
is going along at a snail's pace
who also said the cdc that it should
depend on how much virus there is in the
area
hey cdc we have no virus around here hey
governor
make the decision this is a complete
hypocrisy ainsley
liz caressa dr siegel thank you so much
for being on with us
thank you thank you you're welcome hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now